somebody who lives in the area
somebody who who who kind of knows this
family
gives me updates about dayton hypernova
and it's funny because this person
messaged me two days before thanksgiving
and they said
hey bro gotta talk to this person a lot
like hey man how much you wanna [ __ ]
bet he drops a thanksgiving day video
because i know this family
and every time there's some sort of
holiday or something he uses to be the
victim
thanksgiving night i received the
message going [ __ ] i told you
tough [ __ ] toe to so so this is um
oh before we play we're going to play
dayton but before we play dayton
uh this is kate dorian paradox so who is
dayton aka
he wrote this on his facebook page which
is a public facebook page it's not like
we're taking a private somebody's
private facebook page trust me he wants
attention
so there's this misogynist dude totally
clicking
mocking uh laugh emoticoning on multiple
of my posts that are visible to
non-facebook people
that aren't on my friends list one of
them he was laughing at was
my post showing the woman the women in
history who have pioneered the
beginnings of computing technology i
blocked him
he's probably probably part of that
transformer
organization revenge of the cis we are
organization folks that has repeatedly
sent me stuff
in the mail to harass me for being
outspoken trans woman like a bible in a
quran
plus other stuff after they found my
whole mattress somehow despite it not
being given info we've never
ever given out any of your [ __ ] info
dude nope you're an idiot you give out
you give out your info all the time i in
your own videos
i have changed my instagram name and i'm
not sure what to do about my facebook
name since it can't be changed now and
of course somebody laugh reacted it
um so
again the video is going to be the best
but before we play the video one more
thing
i'm not going to because i would have to
find all the other but
i'm going to surmise something for you
so in the dayton community like every
city
uh there's like there's a gay group you
know there there's the
the where the gay people have their
little thing where they
do fundraisers and go to drag shows and
all that stuff like that right
so there's this woman that does
something called the
that does the something called the
surrealist ball in dayton this is a
woman
uh this woman the gay community loved
them
remember a gay person sent me this in
dayton just so you know this is
the person who sent me this information
a a gay woman
who runs a surrealist ball what she does
is she runs this thing and all the
prophets go to gay people who've been
abused
that's that's her organization
dayton went on a seven paragraph rant
saying how this woman's a piece of [ __ ]
she's
because dayton told her hold on dayton
told her
what her parents do to her or him and
and the skinhead brother and she told
hint and i quote
i deal with people that get brutally
beaten every day dayton what's happening
to you
is not true she told him it's not true
dayton got pissed and was like she
doesn't believe me
she's so now the entire gay community in
dayton because they're all tight-knit if
you know these small towns
the entire gay community in dayton once
advises him
nothing to do with him yeah because he's
making them look all
crazier than they already are because
they you know let's be honest if you're
probably a little nuts but there's got
to be a a dayton hypernov out there
where you're like
jesus christ can you stop it's like
there's a dirty little it's like being
black
and going out with your black cousin and
your black cousin cannot help but get in
a fist fight over a pack of cigarettes
in a gas station and you're like
bro could you just please here's a dirty
ruining this for all you have a dirty
little secret that people don't want you
to talk
about lgbtq community put it to you this
way and i'm sure you know this too but i
i
i i have i have gay friends you
and they i have gay friends and
i don't know if you know this but
there's a lot of gay people that don't
like trans people
they don't they they're trying to
pretend like everybody's together but
that's not necessarily true there's
there's no [ __ ] you can't get
dark-skinned black guys to like like to
like
light-skinned black guys you think
you're gonna get every single [ __ ]
gender under the sun to like each other
gay guys don't even like lesbians and
lesbians don't like gay guys
you know i know that's a broad
generalization but for the most part you
hear that
so anyway uh this is dayton hypernova's
thanksgiving video
without further ado now
get ready because you're going to hear
his family and how terrible they are
because he's secretly recording them on
thanksgiving so i'm sure you're going to
hear them calling him a
loser beating him up just viciously
punching
it's going to get nasty guys i watch
everybody trigger warnings
here we go it's uh thanksgiving
2019 right now um thanksgiving day
um my older brother is a total bigot
he's a skinhead who beats me in front of
my family i'm half his size
he's an overgrown xboxer in training
he beats me senselessly all the time
well when he's not beating me he's going
crazy harassing me
but i'm in the same room as him in a
dress it's really crazy behavior and
it's been happening
years now my sister has small children
and she brings me over here knowing that
he beats me
on thanksgiving my sister and my
brother-in-law
they bring their kids here they have
three kids and they bring them here and
he babysits them every week
and they're over here right now so i'm
getting photoshopped i'm talking to him
all friendly
i mean like there are no problems yeah
cause it's thanksgiving
this household i live here in hiding
from him
he beats me
[Music]
i'm terrified to even talk to you about
on camera
so i won't even be down there to eat
thanksgiving dinner i'll be hiding up
here
eating nothing starving i'll be starving
up here but you can't
hold on but you can go down there
any thanksgiving dinner nobody's
stopping you
you don't you don't want to go down
there and also you know i know we've
said this every time we cover this but
these people are so patient with him
very too patient
in my opinion like you're patient with
it is all the weird creepy filming from
the stairwell
and the muttering like i would just be
like yo knock it off man
knock it the [ __ ] off
as i do on a daily basis because i don't
get paid enough by my parents who are
tax collectors they make plenty of money
they make a lot of money and they never
have paid me minimum wage in my life
i've worked for them like 10 years or
something like that for a long time
and they've never paid me minimum wage i
guess my housemate
and they look down housemates they
definitely look down on trans people
i'm the only trans member of my family
i'm the only openly
sexually different member of the family
then leave
then leave but that you can't do that
and he doesn't know
he doesn't make enough money he doesn't
make enough he makes minimum wage it
makes below minimum wage to do laundry
royce
he has to steal credit cards for health
burritos
he just kade paradox has just posted
this on facebook
because whenever we talk about him i
just get people sending me stuff tonight
i'm getting dropped off at an edm
uh edm night and i'm also walking by the
business space where he want where he's
gonna open his store
yeah i've been hearing a lot about the
store he's gonna open he can't even get
an apartment but he's not
with red finish on it and the new newly
placed for rent sign
on it near the christian supply store
the place i have considered for a long
time uh i've been waiting to open a
boutique and never saw business replace
the former one there
in all this time of starving on one meal
a day
and investing in fashion it's investing
all of my mannequins have shock
rock vibes black and raven angel wings
red angel wings
and the mannequins hang from the
ceilings the boutique will be free
how is that i will be the epitome of
spiritual values for giving you the porn
a daily basis in my shop
this is these delusions of grandeur are
very scary
my parents of christian values for years
have never paid me minimum wage in the
years of cleaning their house
and starving while they made loads from
tax collecting and refusing to respect a
trans person with genetic
with a genetic condition bleeding head
to toe from stress in their home
housing a skinhead older son with a
religious
zealot values he continues
somebody replies to that one of his
friends and they go
have you ever looked into starting an
etsy to help with funding for your store
for your storefront in the meantime no
but upon
opening my boutique i'm going to start a
points based program for my shoppers
when they resell on etsy
the rare fashion items they get for free
from me
wait wait like paddy's bucks a burger i
i
think it's like paddy's box yeah i don't
think that's gonna work
dayton you know most people just pay
money for things
thanksgiving he's outside of my family
everyone else is a normal
heterosexual person who wears the proper
clothes they're supposed to wear
so i'm sorry i tried so cause it's stuff
just started dawning on me because i was
re
so he's gonna start a store where he
doesn't charge people money
points but then how's he gonna make
money how's he gonna pay rent
he's not doing this for the money he's
doing it to lead a
spiritual fashion revolution
this is frustrating man so now he's
going to record now listen now you're
going to hear his
bigoted family this is going to be the
blood and guts right right
fighting get ready here comes get ready
he goes to his little stairwell like he
always does
oh my god the horror the horror
what's going on down there are those
children being murdered
it sounds like they're laughing oh
by the way dayton stayton's got the same
position that i had
when i was like nine eight or nine and
my parents are watching like the
androidized clay stand up special
you just want to listen and i wanted to
watch it and i was like that was that
was my sponsor
yeah because i wasn't allowed to watch
it but like that's normal what i was
doing was normal i was just like i was
trying to sneak a peek at some
forbidden [ __ ] this is so creepy
guys come here come here
wow dude they're abusing the animals too
dude this is some sick
[ __ ] this is gross
could you please stop murdering those
children down there
this is gross this is worse than
ukrainian torture it actually
it's funny because he he posts all this
crazy weird [ __ ] right
but the ambiance of his home
is always the most normal ambiance noise
that you could hear in any lovely
american house exactly you know what i
mean it's always like a couple grandkids
playing around
a couple of adults going so how are you
doing over there with the uh
i heard you applied down there at the
auto parts plant
how did that go oh it's good man yeah
they said uh they're gonna call me back
just do a drug screening and stuff and
then i was like the black you know the
black stuff stuck in the law
yeah man just get my drug screen and my
background check and then they said i
should start it's a union job it's like
yay and you hear some
thump like little feet running around
and it's just dating going look at her
look look at the heart look at this
horrible stuff look at this place i'm
stuck in and you're like
that's like weird man when you have that
level of mental illness and you're that
locked in like
this is like i've grown to really
appreciate these nights i think when i
was like you know when i was younger it
was always like
going to my [ __ ] family's house this
sucks but you get older and you kind of
just appreciate
you know hushed hushed tone
conversations over a whiskey
while the kids are running around and
it's just like you're like ah this is
nice how you been this is good
and he's just to compete and beat me and
he's just too cute to kill me
and the whole the whole town hates me
and they beat me and they beat me and i
don't
and it's i i'm gonna yell i'm gonna go
down there and yell at my mother i'm
gonna scream at my everyone here is
having way too much fun i'm gonna go
scream two inches in front of my
mother's face it's
just insane so he basically just record
you that
i'm not gonna play the whole thing it's
just him for five minutes well four
minutes
recording them having a good time then
back to the back it's very ironic of
them to say
anything about the american way that's
very ironic and messed up
they allow this man to beat me
senselessly he's a skinhead bigot
who doesn't leave this house ever by the
way can i just say something i
definitely believe that sherman has
whooped his ass a couple times for sure
deservedly so in my opinion
i'm i'm not gonna say it wasn't dessert
he probably was very deserving what i'm
saying is he's he does this thing where
he's like he beats me
daily and he could i could you could
probably count on one hand
the number of times sherman's had to
[ __ ] dating up you know what i mean and
it's you know it's
you know even then he probably didn't
really
[ __ ] him up either it was just one of
those fights where you pin somebody down
and you smack them a couple of times and
you're like knock it the [ __ ] off
enough yeah leave mom alone he makes it
sound like like you've ever seen
if if if if dayton hypernova if earp
if his life was the way he accurately
described it he would look like jesse
pinkman at the end of
breaking bad i remember when he was just
had to be and the scars and he was just
flinching at everything
and the only videos we have of anybody
getting attacked in that house is dayton
breaking a wine glass over sherman's
face remember
over his face attacking his mother
attacking his father he's attacked
everybody in that home
he is i we have watched him attack
everyone in that home
remember my favorite dayton hypernova
moment of all time this year has been
when he goes look at us my sister my
brother-in-law and they they know that
he beats me into and she's flowing
through the window and then the
remember the black brother-in-law was
like what's up man
how are you doing and he went like hid
behind the wall and it was just
larry it was the most normal what's up
man why don't you come down
we're having lunch and just please if we
do the youtube rewind can we have dayton
in it too
please please get dating in this [ __ ]
he's transphobe he's a racist can
somebody do that can like one of you
guys
one of you talented fellas out there
that does videos for us
can somebody take some dubsteppy cheesy
music and some transitions and do a
an rotc 9 2019 youtube rewind and just
pull
all of our best scariest horror cows out
and put them all in a little montage
kicking it with ben him screaming at his
mother
frankie be flat excuse me do you ever
i just thought yes mm-hmm that would be
the [ __ ] best
he's a misogynist it's all women
just around our parents in their 70s my
mother and my father i mean
he pushes them around like verbally
makes them feel afraid of him he
intimidates them
you do that your mom is always yelling
at you
not sherman i'm not saying sherman's not
a leech but dude come on
also i love that he always complains
like these people beat me or these
people do this
you steal people's credit cards and run
up thousands of dollars like
to buy clothes that you're never going
to resell but you're going to use the
base system one yeah they you understand
like if i came in
and like royce was like yeah dude you
know my brother or whatever he beats me
went crazy he's been beating me up all
day like oh my god that's [ __ ] up and
then
you go and you ask the brother and go
like what's been going on well royce
stole my credit card and ran up a three
thousand dollar debt
the whole story changes you're like damn
i
whooped his [ __ ] ass dude you know
you know stealing a credit card from a
loved one and stealing their money
is that's an ass whoopable offense
you would have gotten you might had a
broken leg in my family after that ass
whooping
yeah that's you know and it wouldn't
nobody in the family would have been
like i don't think you should be beat he
would have been like
did it yo you stole his credit card what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you dude
it's a beating that's what it is the
cops would show up and go
and uh he says you stole his credit
cards
all right yeah i mean we'll arrest him i
have to arrest you too for credit guard
fraud you know
like you're both going to jail he beats
me in front of them repeatedly
he does violent things toward me right
in front of my sister
i have that on camera as well no you
don't i would do violent things to you
too earl
no you don't because he doesn't he
doesn't have a camera because he doesn't
do those things
i know they were on camera they'd be on
his youtube channel but i'm taking it
i'm taking the argument past
that at this point okay fine he does or
he doesn't
if he does you deserve daily ass
whoopings is my that's my new
my new stance my new stance is no longer
oh nobody's beating you
my new stance is nobody is beating you
enough
you should be beaten every hour on the
hour you should be beaten even when you
don't do [ __ ] just so you get flinchier
i'll tell you what if he lived with me
that [ __ ] laundry would be done
oh yeah be folded too i'd be
trying to fold it like hurting ow ow my
ripper i don't care get it folded
significant at this point because it's
awful
it's 2019. there should not be trans
people half the size of a boxer farmer
boxer
alcoholic bigot who never leaves the
house
and beats them repeatedly all the time
regularly right in front of these people
not even like in the shadows right there
in front of everybody beats me
and nobody does anything adrian
copperblood that's a great
dayton hyperbolic that's a great
that's very funny it's awful it's sad
and that's the video folks and that's uh
that's dayton that's that's our friend
uh dayton hypernova
he uh he's been meant it's been more
than a year right that we've been
covering this guy
but he's been making his videos for like
four or five years about the getting
beat at home and
trying to get on dr phil and god damn it
it didn't work but i had him fooled for
a while pretending i was a [ __ ] doc
a [ __ ] entertainment agent for for dr
phil it worked for a while
it didn't that was it worked but then he
figured it out but it worked for a good
while i had him i was so close so you
get a girl to pretend she's christina
ricci
oh yeah well he wouldn't know everything
about her that'd be really tough